hello everyone and welcome back to the
Gaza hitany Memorial Tournament of 2023
I'm sure you've all heard uh have heard
the news that Prague nananda has won the
tournament uh he wanted a full point
ahead of everyone else we're gonna show
uh what happened very quickly and as the
final three games he played ended in a
draw I decided to show you a game uh
from round two where he faces none other
than the very strong Parham Max Hulu who
is the only 2700 player in the
tournament uh in the live standings of
course Prague is now also over 2700 but
in the actual ratings it is only Parham
who is a 2700 and it's a very nice game
uh so uh well let's just uh let's check
it out so Pregnant has the white pieces
and he opens with Pawn to C4 this is the
English defense and I'm sure you guys
are wondering why not play D4 or E for a
knight to F3 uh those are the uh pretty
uh basic standard moves why would
someone even play Pawn to C4 well it's
very useful as it pretty much avoids all
the uh usual openings and you see you
can still get a very a nice game and if
you want you can even transpose into
some of the openings that can happen
after you play Pawn to D4 because if you
play E4 then you have to know what to
play against the French you have to know
what the play against the standard D5
you have to know what to play against
the appears you have to know what the
plugins the Scandinavian you have to
know what to play against the Karo Khan
you have to know what the plugins the
Sicilian against B6 with this like Owens
defense you have to play uh what play
against Knight F6 like against defense
so you avoid all of that by playing Pawn
to C4 and like I said against D4 you
also have to know a really a lot of
theory and by playing C4 of course you
still have to know a lot of theory but
you uh avoid um uh E4 and D4 theories
that are the the most commonly played so
here Pawn to C4 and of course he's not
going to surprise Parham with Ponto C4
Barham is a 2700 player so he knows his
theory as well uh but uh obviously
Prague prepares something very special
so let's see what's happening here uh we
have Pawn to E5 this is The King's
English version the standard replied to
pawn to see for if your opponent does
not to grab the center with his pawns uh
you will of course grab it by by playing
Pawn to E5 so Knight to C3 Knight to C6
Knight to F3 are a bit more common but
okay uh pretty much we will always
transpose into the Four Knights of the
English uh we have G3 and now Pawn to D5
grabbing the full Center we have
captures captures and now Bishop to G2
we have Knight back to B6 avoiding the
trade uh and now castles with Bishop to
E7 and pawn to A3 so these are all very
well known moves uh White uh is planning
um uh something like B4 Bishop to B2
will put his other Bishop on this
diagonal and then uh later on you will
play something like D3 fight against
Pawn to E4 yeah and so on so it's a very
natural way of developing your pieces
without giving your opponent much
counter play so we have castle spawn to
B4 and now Bishop to E6 we have Pawn to
D3 and pawn to F6 through strengthening
the E5 pawn and again all very very
standard stuff now B Bishop to B2 is
very common here Pro goes for Knight to
the E4 first and now Queen to D7 just
connecting uh the Rooks developing the
queen and now comes Rook to B1 uh here I
was also wondering what if Knight's the
C5 can you just win the bishop pair here
and yes you can it's even been played
once uh White lost in the game but it's
uh it's an okay move the the engine says
it's perfectly fine uh black would just
capture it let's say attacks the night
Knight comes to D5 and okay you won the
bishop pair you can claim the semi-open
B file for yourself but uh black is also
uh very happy with his setup here uh but
okay Rook to B1 is considered to be
stronger we have broken 8 to B8 also you
don't want your Rook on this diagonal if
the position opens up and now comes
Bishop to B2 and there is a game where
Rook after d it was played Parham goes
for Pawn to A6 and it is now as of move
13 that we have a completely new game so
Prague continues development Queen to C2
now he wants to bring the other Rook
over to C1 and his development will be
complete but Parham says Nope not on my
watch he plays Bishop to A2 which forces
The Rook back now you could put the Rook
on A1 but you kinda brought the Rook
from A1 to B1 so he plays Rook to C1 and
now the other Rook will not be able to
occupy the C1 Square so Rook B to C1 and
not just Queen to E6 keeping the bishop
protected because you don't want any
discoveries here and then just losing
that bishop or basically losing a pawn
for for the exchange of Bishops and now
we have Knight E to D2 the problem is if
you go something like Rook F to D1 then
Bishop here will cost you the exchange
so Prague plays Knight E to D2 now the
B3 square is covered and now Pawn the A5
but prog doesn't Advance the pawn to B5
something you'd expect he first trades
characters captures and now the Knight
on the rim as of course you all know is
dim or Grim or maybe they've you know
found another rhyme that goes with a rim
uh who knows uh Bishop to C3 and okay
very unpleasant the Knight here is under
attack also the bishop is being
pressured and you don't really want to
bring the Knight back if you just play
Knight to the C6 then look at this Rook
to A1 and already black is in big
trouble how do you defend the bishop and
if you go from Bishop back to the five
E4 traps the bishop so you know not the
best so Rook back to A8 uh basically
this is uh sort of the entire game is
just these two gentlemen keeping their
opponent from uh opponent's Rook from
reaching optimal squares uh so Bishop to
H3 by frog not saying uh okay do you
want to trade Bishops Prague basically
wants to capture on A5 and then capture
the C7 Pawn this will win him material
but while he's at it he would very much
enjoy trading uh even more material so
grabbing material and then just trading
down which is of course the the best way
to go and it's a very dangerous line to
go for even though this classical chess
and you have time to calculate just to
give you an example for example captures
captures on A2 comes with checks so King
h8 now you capture on A5 real captors
you lose the C7 pawn attack the bishop
and the B7 Pawn so only one can be
rescued Knight the D5 attacks and
defense and now Rook captures here uh
wins you two pawns and okay it does look
like okay two pawns should be winning
but it's not really two pawns because
black has Knight c three attacks the
queen in the E2 pawn and once you move
the queen you will lose the E2 Pawn with
check King the H1 and now you will you
will only be up one point and it seems
like okay you can't capture an A3 with
the Rook because the bishop is hanging
but it's even worse if you play Bishop
captures on A3 you have to play Rook to
C5 here and attack the White Queen
because if you capture on A3 then Queen
the C7 threatens Checkmate and The Rook
on A5 so this is uh what you have to
calculate in this position after proc
plays Bishop to H3 if you are to
successfully trade uh Bishops here and
of course Parham decides against it he
plays Queen back to F7 and now Bishop
captures an A5 frog will take the
offered Pawn Rook captures and now Queen
captures on C7 uh putting pressure on
the B7 pawn and the Knight here so
Bishop to d8 attacks the queen and also
another queen defends the B7 pawn and
Prague finds his possession better he
does not want to trade Queens he
controls more space so Queen C3 just
puts pressure on The Rook here and now
Rook the A6 again forcing your opponent
to Rook to a less optimal Square again
kind of the the theme of the game and
now Pawn to D4 another beautiful
positional move by frog uh saying that
okay I'm attacking E5 twice you have to
react to this if you capture then I just
improve the position of my pieces so
very natural move uh he captures on D4
Knight captures and now Bishop to E7
uh getting uh the the bishop to this
diagonal uh maybe later on it can come
even to C5 which would be which would be
okay but you are also putting pressure
on that A3 Pawn so how do you react to
this uh Rook to A1 and now how how do
you play this uh it seems that uh the
eighth three Pawn is attacked twice
maybe you could capture it maybe you
could play something like Rook captures
on A3 sure you could you attack the
queen you defend the bishop looks very
nice but then the queen comes to C7 and
again it doesn't look uh yeah it doesn't
look like much how are you defending the
uh the B7 Pawn also you have to be very
very careful because Bishop to E6 is a
constant threat if Bishop to E6 lands
not while the Bishop is on A2 but you
can easily imagine Rook captures bishop
and then Bishop D6 and of off goes the
queen so uh here after Rook to A1 uh
it's not great I mean if you just go
back Bishop D5 and then Pawn to E4
forces the bishop off of this diagonal
again Bishop to E6 is a problem so here
batam actually finds a very clever
defense he plays Knight to the A4 which
attacks the queen a rook also defends
the E6 Square so you don't have to worry
about Bishop to E6 but Prague also finds
a very tricky move Queen to C2 that's
why the previous move was so important
now you shift the queen over to C2 with
Tempo and also you are still pressuring
the Knight on A4 so The Rook can't
really go uh that many places and again
Bishop to D5 will just be met with Pawn
to A4 so we can't really go into that so
Bishop to C5 again Parham finds a very
very clever maneuver and now Knight for
the B3 seems like he's giving Parham a
way out but it does require him to give
up his light Square Bishop so he does
save the bishop is just not gonna be on
the board anymore Bishop captures on B3
Knight captures with a double attack on
the bishop on C5 and Bishop to A7 and
now look at the parham's pieces here
that's just not a very good piece
coordination there and frog plays Bishop
back to G2 he abandons the uh you know
uh the Quest for this E6 square but he
goes uh over to the B7 pawn and he will
now put pressure on it and how do you
continue this game it's much much more
difficult than you'd think because of
the weird placement of the pieces on the
A5 let's say you play Rook d8 a
Perfectly Natural developing move you
claim the D file the open file for your
Rook now look at this rotate the D1 and
okay not much to look at let's say you
play rotate the D6 you trade here let's
say captures captures and now look at
this queen to C8 check you have to block
with the queen and now Queen to C4 check
will pick up the Knight on A4 so the
really just a very very poor placement
of the pieces on on the a file so Parham
goes Pawn to F5 he wants to play Pawn to
F4 and open up the f file for his Queen
and Rook so it's going to be a bit more
problematic for proc to develop his Rook
from the F1 square but Prague just plays
Pawn to E3 and again uh you you really
should play this King to h8 move on the
previous move on this move uh as you
know that one of the Rooks is coming to
D1 and then Bishop to D5 will be a
problem uh but Parham doesn't he plays
Pawn to G5 he really wants to get that
pawn to F4 move in but now Prague Waits
no longer Rook 8 to D1 now threatening
Bishop to D5 so King to h8 has to be
played and now Rook to D5 Rook to D5 is
a beautiful centralizing move by Prague
uh that just controls the entire board
it puts even more pressure on the F5
Square so the queen and Rook have to
remain here and just a very strong move
all around adds a more more protection
to the C5 Square so black can't really
bring any pieces here uh what can uh
what can he do here well he can advance
the pawn to F4 it's even the top move
recommended by the engine but just to
give you an idea of what is happening
here let's say Knight to D4 uh now it's
a very strong piece you wanna get rid of
it Bishop captures on the four Rook
captures and F captures on E3 F captures
an E3 and now even Rook to F6 so it
seems you've mobilized all of your
pieces but look at this Rook captures on
F6 Queen captures and now okay you can't
capture the Knight on A4 because if you
do this then just Queen to have to check
and you are getting checkmated here so
okay you don't do that but uh uh you you
don't have to after Queen captures on F6
to just play H3 clear this Square for
your king and now well the the black
king will not be able to survive here
the the White Queen will occupy this
diagonal the bush will occupy uh this or
this diagonal and you're not going to be
able to survive this this will be just
completely winning so instead I have to
Rook to D5 we have rooked the C6 now
attacking the queen a little bit here uh
Prague goes Queen to D2 and now uh we
have Rook the F6 now really preparing
Pawn to F4 and while Prague could maybe
uh play Queen T5 to go after the pieces
here then maybe even Force something
like Rogue back to A6 or even B5
defending the Knight and then the queen
defends the A7 Bishop uh he goes for
Rook to D7 he just goes after the B7
Pawn uh and now Pawn to F4 here with
this Rook the B5 move uh Prague even
perhaps allowed Parham the possibility
of a clever defense with Bishop to B6
it's it's such a silly looking move that
no one would play it but uh you know if
it holds it holds I mean the B7 Pawn is
defended but you know you'd very rarely
think of such a move so here Ponte F4
was played uh Parham just went all out
but now the position is of course
completely winning for Prague and I'm
sure you guys uh realized that without
even calculating Rook capture some B7
was played now the queen is saying
Parham plays F captures on E3 also
attacking prox Queen but now the move
that Parham overlooked Rook captures
Queen on F7 and he was in this position
on move 36 that parhamocks will resigned
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here let me just uh really quickly
check what was the situation on the
clock here
uh yeah doesn't seem to be yeah okay
they had like uh a minute and a half
each when this was played okay for a
classical game we could consider that
both of them were in time travel uh so
you know what are you gonna do uh but
yeah here you resign because after a e
captures on D2 there's Rook characters
on A7 and now after Rook captures on F2
hoping to clear the D1 Square for the
queen uh to be promoted to then just
Knight captures on D2 and now Rook
cannot capture because the rule can have
fate would be hanging so you have to
trade hero captures Bishop captures but
now after all is said and done of course
you can see that Prague is up a full
bishop and of course in a completely
winning position
uh so beautifully beautifully played by
Prague uh he wins the tournament uh not
just wins it by a full point ahead of
the field uh let me just uh give you so
Prague first place uh sun and sirigov
and I'm in Tabata by second place with
five and a half then with uh five we
have five Eleanor and maximatlakov with
three and a half Parham aksulu here and
Adam causa KIRO shivchenko uh with three
out of nine in nine plays and Peter
prohaska uh in last place with two and a
half out of nine and here are the uh top
uh let me just uh load this up
sorry my bad let me just uh
I prepared it only I've saved it at a
different folder there we go
alright so here it is here are the
standings or one would imagine they are
sorry what sorry about that
yeah there we go uh so these are the the
live ratings uh for uh some of the
players after uh for Prague basically
after winning this tournament so as you
can see uh he is up an incredible 17.3
points he is in uh 31st in the world
currently he's a live ratings
2707.3 about him lost 16 points so but
he's still a 2700 player about 16 points
is a lot to lose he dropped down eight
eight places and you can see some other
like Anish is down five and a half he's
been playing some games Mama Jarvis up
four and a half Gucci shop one plus six
uh La Quang Liam uh plus nine then we
have visit on plus four pental Hare
Krishna plus three also Shanks and minus
two so not a lot of Shifting basically
the the biggest shifts are uh as you can
see he's 31st but he went up 16. uh 16
uh places so absolutely incredible by
Prague and uh yeah great tournament he
played it brilliantly if you remember he
started by winning four games then he
lost I'm in tabatabai then he won
another game and then he finished
strongly by just getting three draws
basically he only uh had to go strong in
the final round he faced rather slavoit
in the final round and he only needed a
draw he had the white pieces he uh
exchanged uh very nicely and he just
drew that game to win the tournament of
course if uh if he wanted to win he
probably could have played for the win
but you know you're not gonna mess up
with your uh chance to win a tournament
by you know pushing too hard for a win
in the final game that you don't need
some people do that uh you know but it's
you know if you want to win the
tournament maybe no don't do that and um
yeah very nicely done by probably
congratulations to him on winning uh you
know pretty much effortlessly against
the 2700 player like Parham aksula just
a beautiful positional Masterpiece uh we
can definitely learn a lot from Prague
and also uh well I know you guys
probably don't like the English opening
but uh you know you really do avoid a
lot and if you give it a chance maybe
learn uh like four four most popular
lines you will get a very very playable
positions and also uh to finish it off
with a fun story uh I um someone
published on Twitter today
um uh sort of a quote by me uh that The
Rook on the seventh rank is often called
a pig and it's something that I often
say in my videos but it's not my quote I
I've actually took the quote from Josh
waitskin I've uh you know some I don't
know 20 years ago I really enjoyed the
Chess Master Series I had the Chess
Master Grand Master Edition and then you
had the Joshua skin Academy in that
program and I really enjoyed it and I
really you know I can still hear Josh
waitskin's voice in my head he he has
such a beautiful way of addressing uh
you know people and positions and things
and he often said that and then someone
attributed it to me on Twitter I said no
I do is from Josh waitskin but I also
remember from Joshua weights can sing it
in the Chess Master Grand Master Edition
series that he picked it up from his
teacher who is the legendary Bruce
pandolfini uh so you know I also said
that and but it probably even predates
that and then someone said but yeah even
tartakovar said it uh sometime you know
a long time ago and then someone found
on the history website by uh Edward
winter who is an absolute Legend when it
comes to chess history 100 years ago in
1923 uh that uh David yanovsky actually
called the Rooks on the seventh rank
blind pigs so not just a pig a blind pig
as they often wreak havoc when you just
probably a blind pig because they just
gobble up everything without even
watching what it is so uh probably that
it was uh even Saturday was on the page
213 of the golden treasury of Chess By
Francis uh welmut from 1943 was that uh
you know quote and a position from a
game that I believe iyanovski was
commenting from 1923. uh but yeah I got
attributed to it but I you know I said
no that's not my quote sorry about that
uh I have no idea where it's from so it
could maybe it's probably even pretty
daisyonowski from 1923 who knows if you
know where it comes from be sure to
share with us that we would all very
much love to learn uh but yeah that's
the game understandings and the live
ratings and a little bit of uh you know
me rambling about Chess history hope you
enjoyed that I would like to thank James
Eugene Cashman Rod Hill Gage wedland uh
Gary chomuk and Gustav parak for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
uh thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon probably continuing with
some games from the bullet Chess
Championship Finals that are currently
happening so if you have any of your
favorites I I know that Magnus is
playing galileza now malwareza was
beating him 3-0 while I was uh recording
this so who knows what is happening now
just use hashtag suggestion and I will
go over your suggestions so once again
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day